[Music]
i guarantee you
that at some point everything's gonna go
south on you
ready you're going to say this is it
this is how i end commander mark is dead
we have to go
now you can either accept that
or you can get to work this will come as
quite a shock to my crewmates
and to nasa and of the entire world
but i'm still alive
surprise here's the rub
it's gonna be four years for another
mission to reach me
and i'm going to have designed the last
31 days
so i got to make water and grow food on
a planet where nothing grows
but if i can't figure out a way to make
contact with nasa and none of this
matters anyway
we've got an incoming message
[Music]
okay so let's do the math i have enough
food to last for 50 days
he's going to starve to death long
before we can help
so i'm gonna have to science the [ __ ]
out of this
he's 50 million miles away from home
he's totally alone the hell is he
thinking right now
i am the greatest botanist on this
i planet how to save mark watney but we
need the hermes crew we either have a
high chance of killing one
or a low chance of killing six i'm not
risking their lives
it's bigger than one person no it's not
nasa rejected the mission so if we do
this we're talking
mutiny if anything goes wrong we die
do you realize how crazy this is we had
no other option
no matter what happens
tell the world
tell my family and i never stop
fighting to make it home
[Music]
hey guys it's a girl
do you have any idea who the father is
shut up for story time
all right let's go three two one
[Music]
this is dr david jordan our mission is
to intercept a research pod from mars
16 steps to fix a shower i'm an
astronaut not a gym teacher
this is the first capsule ever to come
back from the planet we have visual
confirmation
i said this could be a major scientific
breakthrough
come on come on come on come on come on
we're looking at the first proof of life
beyond earth
lowering oxygen more carbon dioxide
that's beautiful you're finally a daddy
it's gonna be a big custody battle over
this one
are you gonna bring the martian back to
earth no we're gonna keep it up here
we're gonna study where it's safe
look how fast it's growing every single
cell is a muscle cell
and a nerve cell all muscle
or brain how smart is this thing
these creatures wiped out mars millions
of years ago
if we let it get to earth we'll risk all
human life
let's kill the thing
good night moon good night roon
good night cow jumping over the moon
good night light and the red balloon
what is the prime instinct of any life
form
to survive grenade stars
we've lost all communication good night
air we'll hit the atmosphere in 39
minutes
but it could good noises everywhere
[Music]
what are you gonna do with it i'm gonna
give it something socially responsible
to do
can't we just let it go this thing needs
to learn how to adapt
all right let's mask like the rest of us
[Music]
this world's a treasure there's been
times to leave for a while now
your daughter's generation will be the
last to survive on earth
you're the best pilot we ever had get
out there
and save the world everybody ready to
say goodbye to our
solar system to our galaxy
here we go
right here
[Music]
i want to get down fast don't we
actually we want to get there in one
piece
hang on
we have a mission our mission does not
work if the people on earth are dead by
the time we pull it off
[Music]
we got this far far than any human in
history well not far enough
[Music]
make it count where's the mountains
those are mountains
the waves
yes you are yes you are
you might have to decide between seeing
your children again
and the future of the human race
we'll find a way that we always have
i come from earth a planet of outlaws
my name is peter quill
there's one other name you might know me
by star-lord
who star-lord man legendary outlaw
guys forget it
so here we are a thief
two thugs an assassin
and a maniac but we're not going to
stand by as evil wipes out the galaxy
i guess we're stuck together partners
are you telling me the fate of 12
billion people
is in the hands of these criminals oh
[Music]
i look around you know what i see losers
but mine's giving us a chance to do what
something good something bad a bit of
both
oh what the hell i don't got that long a
lifespan anyway
[Music]
but you're in love with me
[Music]
they call themselves the guardians of
the galaxy
this might not be the best idea
[Music]
dave do you mind if i ask you a personal
question
no no
i've wondered whether you might be
having some second thoughts about the
[Music]
mission
[Music]
how do you mean rumors about something
being dug up on the moon
i never gave these stories much credence
but particularly in view of some of the
other things that have happened
i find them difficult to put out of my
mind
open the pod bay doors please hell
open the pod bay doors hal
[Music]
i'm sorry dave i'm afraid i can't do
that
what are you talking about how
[Music]
this conversation can serve no purpose
anymore
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you jake sully
i'd like to talk to you about a fresh
start on a new world
you'd be making a difference
[Music]
i became a marine for the hardship i
told myself i can pass any test a man
can pass
all i ever wanted was a single thing
worth fighting for
ladies and gentlemen
you're not in kansas anymore you're on
pandora
you should see your faces up there
beyond that fence
we have an indigenous population called
the navi
this is why we're here because this
little gray rock sells for 20 million a
kilo
their village happens to be resting on
the richest deposit and they need to
relocate
you're supposed to be finding a
diplomatic solution
the concept is to drive these remotely
controlled bodies called avatars
they're grown from human dna mixed with
dna of the natives marine in an avatar
body
that's a potent mix you get me what i
need i'll see two get your legs back
your real legs yes sir looks like you
this is your avatar just relax and let
your mind go blank
it shouldn't be hard for you
jake it's real simple
i want you to learn from the inside i
want you to gain their trust
[Music]
all this is your fault i need your help
[Music]
haven't gotten lost in the woods have
you you forget what team you're playing
for
strong prey on the week and nobody does
anything
you've got one hour you knew this would
happen
everything changed jake it's crazy here
poor rich has taken over he's rolling
guess we better stop him
they've sent us a message that they can
take whatever they want
but we will send them a message
get this this is our last
[Music]
hello
he asking me on a date
she didn't seem that impressed
wow you clean up pretty good yourself
you two look fine this evening
we're on a date very nice it took you
long enough to ask
so why did you give up your life on
earth
we boarded the avalon with a destination
years hibernation means he'll wake up in
a new century on a new planet
but a year ago everything changed
do you know what's going on nobody else
is awake
i think something went wrong with the
hibernation pies we woke up too soon
90 years too soon this can't be
happening we have to go back to sleep
we can't
something's wrong something big
what do we do now
do you trust me
[Music]
this ship is gonna go i have to do this
[Music]
there's something i have to tell you
there's no reason we woke up early
who are you
i'm no one
i was raised to do one thing i've got
nothing to fight for
nothing will stand in our way
i will finish
what you started
there are stories about what happened
it's true
all of it
the dark side
[Music]
a jedi
they're real
[Music]
the force it's calling to you
just let it in
[Music]
a king has his reign
and then he dies
it's inevitable
these are ancient civilizations that
were separated by centuries and yet
this same pictogram was discovered at
every one of them
they're smiling i think they want us to
come and find them
we're all here because of map you two
kids found in a cave
not a map an invitation from whom
[Music]
please tell me you can read that
prometheus are you seeing this
whatever that probe is picking up it's
reading live for
to go where yes we were so wrong
take us home if they don't stop to go
back
big things have small beginnings
[Music]
2742 requesting release
i'm here to harvest i have the location
of a massive deposit of orlac
the queen's lair by my estimation it's
the largest anyone's ever seen
[Music]
someone is approaching where are you
from
nowhere go poetic
and all my time in the green little girl
[Applause]
we're in the same trough you and i you
don't have a ship
no i don't but you will find a way to
get home if you find that buried
treasure
why should i trust you you're a killer i
am indeed
but are you i can offer protection
i sing together we ravage the queen's
lair
even spite of course
i have sustained a wound i was hoping
you had some juice
here is our offer i don't understand
put a girl
that is a bold offer
you're trying to trick me
it was all in the name of
self-preservation birdie it was nothing
personal
uh
today the 18th of march 1965
the mad
for the first time in the history of
mankind a man has walked in outer space
i don't understand the pressure in the
suit keeps increasing okay
[Music]
are you suggesting that i leave them in
orbit their soldiers they're prepared to
die to protect their country's interests
mama will daddy be here when i wake up
again he'll do his very best
[Music]
so
this is major roy mcbride i'm attempting
to reach
dr clifford mcbride this is dr mcbride's
son
dad i'd like to see you again
i recall how we used to watch black
white movies together
musicals were your favorite
[Applause]
i remember you tutoring me in math
you instilled in me a strong work ethic
you should know i've chosen a career
that you would approve of
[Music]
i've dedicated my life to the
exploration of space
and i thank you for that
[Music]
what is happening out there is a crisis
of
unknown magnitude
[Music]
we believe your father may be involved
my father's dead
what exactly are you requiring for me
exploration isn't always a noble venture
we have to hold out the possibility that
your father may be hiding from us
[Music]
we have a job to do are you ready
i'm ready
explorer's been hit explorer
i can't see you anymore
[Music]
i can't i can't
nothing i see nothing you have a visual
of explorer no you have a vehicle of iss
you need to focus
gulp
so where's home after stone like zurich
illinois
is there somebody down there looking out
thinking about you
i had a daughter
a little girl with brown hair tell her
that i'm not quitting
uh
[Music]
you